RAMONA ROMERO: Good afternoon, Welcome.
You're a really scary group of people.
Thank you so much
for being here.
It is great that you came back to the
University to celebrate the
contributions that women have made to
Princeton and to society. My name is
Ramona Romero and you can take as many
pictures with me as you want okay? Just
no pictures of the justices after a
couple of minutes. My name is Ramona
Romero and for almost four years I have
been the general counsel of the
University. As a lawyer, as a lawyer it is
a true true honor for me to introduce
three legal superstars, Supreme Court
Justice Sonia Sotomayor, Class of 19--
Class of 1976, Justice Elena Kagan Class
Class of 1981,
and Heather Gerken, Class of 1991, the
recently appointed dean of the Yale Law
School. As the lawyers in the audience
know, the Supreme Court begins its term
on the first Monday in October, so we are
particularly grateful to the justices
for having come today during this very,
very busy week. We're also very grateful --
that was unintentional -- we're also
grateful to Dean Gerken, who has also had
an unusually demanding beginning of the
term. This could take a long time guys. So
you know, I first met Dean Gerken a few
years ago when I was new to Princeton
and she was a University trustee. Based
on our interactions, her unassuming
manner would give you no clue of her
many accomplishments. After graduating
from Princeton summa cum laude, she
earned her degree from the University of
Michigan Law School again with the
highest honors. Following her clerkship
on the 9th circuit and for Justice
David Souter on the U.S. Supreme Court,
she worked at a law firm for a few years.
A mutual friend who was a colleague of
hers at the law firm describes her as
phenomenally talented and too good for
the law firm world. Dean Gerken entered
academia in the year 2000, earning tenure
at Harvard and then at Yale. When she was
appointed dean last year, the first woman
to hold that position,
Dean Gerken's predecessor said that
Yale Law School is very lucky to be able
to draw on the energy, brilliance and
leadership of Heather Gerken. This is a
time of change in our country and in
legal education, and Heather is perfectly
suited to take the helm of this
extraordinary place. And I think we've
seen evidence of that already, but lest
you think that Dean Gerken is all
about legal scholarship, I encourage you
to Google her name after the program's
over, to Google her name and the words
vampire novel. Now on to the toughest
part of my assignment, introducing two
women who really need no introduction,
Justices Sonia Maria Sotomayor and
Elena Kagan. Justice Kagan and Sotomayor
have much in common. Both are from New
York and both -- clock is ticking -- but
are from New York and both are serious
baseball fans, although they had although
they do favor different teams and only
one of those teams is doing well.
At Princeton both majored in history, excelled
academically, and graduated with the
highest honors. Since they left our
campus, both have blazed many trails. For
example, Justice Kagan was the first
female dean of the Harvard Law School
and she was also the first woman and so
far the only woman to serve as Solicitor
General of the United States.
Justice Sotomayor is the first and only
Hispanic American ever appointed to the
U.S. Supreme Court
and the first and only woman of color to
ever serve on that court. Clock is
ticking guys. After graduating from
Princeton, Justices Kagan and Sotomayor
traveled different paths to their
appointments as the third and fourth
female justices in our nation's history.
Justice Sotomayor, who
attended Yale Law School, honed her
courtroom skill as a prosecutor in New
York, worked at a law firm, and spent 17
years as a federal trial and appellate
judge before her elevation to the
Supreme Court in 2009. She issued
hundreds of decisions. However none is
better known than a decision she issued
enjoining
that an injunction she issued that
effectively ended a baseball strike that
had forced the cancellation of the 1994
World Series. As a former baseball Major
League Baseball player testified during
her confirmation hearing, with one
decision
she brought players and owners back to
the table and rescued the 1995 baseball
season. So you see, putting aside Justice
Oliver Wendell Holmes, who authored a
mystifying to lawyers Supreme Court
opinion in 1922 that exempted baseball
from the antitrust laws, I think it is
safe to say the Sonia Sotomayor is the
only justice in our nation's history who
can take credit for saving the national
pastime.
When Justice Sotomayor was nominated to
the Supreme Court New York, district
attorney Robert Morgenthau
noted that throughout her career she had
exhibited wisdom, intelligence,
collegiality, and good character. New York
City Mayor Michael Bloomberg praised her
sharp and agile mind, her wealth of
unique experience, and fact that she
is an independent jurist
who does not fit squarely into an
ideological box. Her appointment was a
particularly joyful and proud moment for
the Hispanic legal community.
She was active within our communities
throughout her 17 years on the bench and
was and remains deeply respected and
beloved not only for her accomplishments
but also for her extraordinary
commitment to giving back. As someone
who knows her well said to me recently,
her commitment is authentic. She has
never forgotten her roots in the South
Bronx, prefers Puerto Rican food above
all others, and means everything she says
and does.
She's also, based on my own observations
over the years, one of the most genuine,
gracious, humble, and decent
people on the planet.
Now Justice Kagan, her post-Princeton path to the Supreme Court
was equally impressive. After she earned
her law degree from Harvard Law School,
she clerk on the Court of Appeals in D.C.
and for Justice Marshall on the U.S.
Supreme Court. Following her clerkship,
she ventured ever so briefly into
private practice. Subsequently she taught
at the University of Chicago and at
Harvard, where she later became dean and
served in both the Clinton and Obama
administrations. A mutual friend who
worked with Justice Kagan when she was a
counselor to President Clinton told me
that she is known as a brilliant jurist
for her talents range far beyond
that. As dean of the Harvard Law School
she was beloved because  she was
approachable and responsive to students
and faculty, and I'm happy to add alumni
to that list. A few years after
she became dean, Justice Kagan
hosted the law school's first-ever reunion
of Hispanic alumni. A large group of us
met with her. We were determined and I
mean determined to find out what she
intended to do to correct the law school's
failure to hire Hispanic faculty. Over a
decade later, I still remember how
impressed I was by the directness and by
the grace and humor with which she
handled our spirited questioning. Those
qualities including her sense of humor
were apparent in her confirmation
hearing in 2010. There, to quote President
Obama, the members of the Senate
Judiciary Committee got a good sense of
her judicial philosophy, her commitment
to the rule of law,
her rich understanding of our
Constitution, and of course where she can
be found on Christmas Day.
Let me conclude by acknowledging
how fortunate we are that
these three women have chosen lives of
service and are now in positions, in
positions to influence the evolution of
American law. As Justice Kagan -- As Justice
[inaudible] of the Massachusetts
Supreme Court said during Justice
Kagan's confirmation hearing, the
presence of women and minorities on a
court has an impact on the overall
decision-making that goes beyond the
opinions of the female or
minority judges themselves. They
influence how the other judges think
and how they analyze the law. Justice
Sotomayor, Justice Kagan thank you for
your service to the American people and
for being here today to share your
unique experiences and thank you Dean
Gerken for moderating today's
conversation and for your contributions
to legal scholarship and for your
courage and leadership at this time in
our nation's history.
Now, now.
HEATHER GERKEN: So it is it is wonderful to be here.
It feels so sustaining to be around so many
women, to hear so many women's voices at
this moment. And so I am just gonna cut
to the chase as I know you do not want
to hear from me. And we have a series of
questions that you have all helped
shape with your own contributions that
I'm going to ask the justices over the
course of the evening - about their life
here at Princeton, their careers, advice
they'd have for all the young women in
the room. So I'll just get started and
just start with something very short. So
one of you came from Manhattan and
another came from the Bronx. Why did you
come to Princeton University? And, Chris,
yes, I am setting this up for you so that
you can put it on the website.
[LAUGHTER]
SONIA SOTOMAYOR: Well for me it was my high school
coach in debate club, and he guided, got guided
to Princeton by one of the teachers at
our high school. We were not a feeder
school and Kenny was the first of our
high school graduates to attend an Ivy
League school and he came to Princeton
and obviously he didn't flunk out and they took
a chance on me. It is a long story for
those who - I've said it at the first She
Roars, so you may have to listen to that
tape. But suffice it to say, I went to
Harvard and I met an interviewer who was
dressed in a black dress, beautifully
white coffered hair, pearled earrings, a
black and white poodle next to her,
a red rug oriental rug in a white couch.
Now in my house, all couches had plastic
on them and you never bought a white
couch because the kids would mess it up.
I literally ran out of that room. It's
the only time I've run away from
something and left and told the assistant -
ELENA KAGAN: Wait, so you went to Princeton instead?
SOTOMAYOR: I did. I went - [LAUGHTER]
And I'm going to tell the story of why. I went,
I tried out Harvard. They were too
radical for me. This is an amazing story.
But I came to Princeton and my friend,
who was my friend, and he had a bunch of
other friends that were like him and not
like most Princetonians
and I got fooled. [LAUGHTER] And that's how I
ended up here. There is a reason to have posses
around you. For those of you in education,
you know that there are many colleges
who bring kids from similar
neighborhoods if they want to integrate
their schools better because there is a
comfort in meeting people who are more
like you at least at first. I obviously
got used to Princeton but it does take a
while if you're from a different environment.
GERKEN: Justice Kagan?
KAGAN: Well I'm not quite sure why I came to
Princeton. Actually first off I want to
say it's great to be here.
[APPLAUSE, CHEERS]
I haven't been back for a few years, so I
was, I was just saying to Heather and to
Sonia that, you know, Reunions are at the
worst time of year for us. So I haven't, I
haven't made it back to my last couple,
and it's absolutely wonderful to be here
and to be here especially at an event
like this. Give yourselves some applause.
What? [APPLAUSE] Wow. Wow. What a crowd.
SOTOMAYOR: I would have never
imagined a crowd like this when I came here. No,
I mean, we were, that I was in the third
year of women, you were in the fifth.
I had many classes where I was the only
woman in the room. To see a gymnasium
filled of alumni and to see all the
women students up there? [APPLAUSE]
KAGAN: So I went to a great public school  in New York, Hunter College High
School. Yeah. Very few people
went to Princeton from
my high school. [inaudible] It sent a lot of
people to a lot of Ivy League schools, but but
Princeton was not on the list.
And, but I came down here and I just fell
in love with the place. It was one of
those glorious spring days and the
campus was looking incredibly beautiful.
And you know what basically I kind of
think that people do not know what
they're doing when they're 17 and
they're picking colleges.
GERKEN: I'm looking at my daughter who's 16.
KAGAN: Yeah I would love to
be able to say I had a great reason for
coming to Princeton, but mostly it was I
caught it on a really sunny beautiful day.
[LAUGHTER]
GERKEN: Justice Sotomayor,
you were just talking a little bit
about the few years after women were
admitted here. You've described
yourself publicly as a fish out of water
at Princeton. I wonder if you might say a
little bit more about what that was like.
SOTOMAYOR: It's hard to describe to people.
I might I think my favorite story is a couple of
days into being here. I'm sitting outside
of Dillon Gym and there is a classmate
there who's from Alabama. Yep
and she starts talking to me about how
her great-grandfather had been in
Princeton, her grandfather, her father, and
two of her brothers, and how amazing it
was for her now to join their ranks. And
I am sort of looking at this, and I'm the
first generation going to college in my
family, and I'm thinking how many
generations is that. But coming up to me
were my roommate, who was a
Mexican-American,
and a Puerto Rican friend, and they were
talking Spanish. And the young woman
standing, next sitting next to me says,
That's why I love this place. It has so
many different people. And I'm looking at
her with her Southern drawl and
thinking, And I thought you were the
different one. But the longer I stayed at
Princeton, the more different I felt
than most of my classmates. Remember I
don't think it's as true today. This
was this this was the most non-northern
school of the South. That's what it was
most famous for and that environment had
eating clubs and not all the Ivies did
at the time. And it was just opening its
doors to women, and there were still a
lot of alumni who were not happy with
that state of affairs. And I think most
of the men on campus liked it a lot, but
there were still some who really would
have preferred an all-male college or
university. And so when you feel like a
fish out of water, I don't think you ever
completely get past it. If you want to
know when I finally figured out I belong,
when they made me a trustee.
That's not to say that I didn't identify
as a Princetonian, because I did, and it
likely was the most influential
experience of my life in terms of
transforming me from the world I came
from into the world I was entering. But
it I think I said it best when I
accepted a prize at the end of my four
years, which is, We all march to different
drummers and the beauty of a place like
Princeton is to let all of us march to
our own drummers while still being on
the same parade ground. And so that was
important to me.
GERKEN: So Justice Kagan, I want to ask you a little bit about something
that is so important to students these
days, which is mentorship and  this is
a little bit personal for me because I
was a junior faculty member worried
about getting tenure, and Justice Kagan
was then Dean Kagan and not only an
extraordinary dean of Harvard Law School
but managed to be a mentor to me. So I'm
intensely grateful for that and I just
want to -
KAGAN: I don't really think
you needed mentorning
GERKEN: You would be surprised. So I
wondered who were who were the most
influential mentors in your career and
and what kind of advice did they give
you as you moved along?
KAGAN: Well I think at
Princeton, I'll start with Princeton.
In Princeton it was my senior thesis
adviser who maybe is here, Sean Wilentz.
He's still a history professor here. Okay,
so there he is in the front row because
he was my senior thesis adviser.
And you know some well I did my junior
paper with him, my junior paper
in the spring, and then my senior thesis.
And Sean Wilentz taught me how to write,
which is a useful thing to know. And and
and so I'm I'm forever grateful to him
for that and for all the advice he gave
me along the way and for convincing me
that I really didn't want to be a
historian after all.
GERKEN: You wrote him 153 pages.
KAGAN: I did yeah. 150 pages on a subject
that was sort of the bane of my
existence as I was going through my
confirmation proceedings, because I wrote
on the history of the Socialist Party
in New York City, in the early
20th century, and from this everybody
assumed that I must be a socialist.
And so, and you know -
SOTOMAYOR: She's not?
KAGAN: This year that's a popular.
This year
This year that's popular. It was not so
popular among many members of the
Judiciary Committee when I was trying to
get through the process. But you know the
judges I clerked for were
unbelievable in different ways.
Judge Mikva was somebody who had
served in all different parts of
government and then he ended up being
really important to my career, not only
because what he taught me when I was a
clerk for him, but because he ended up at
the White House. And one day I picked up
the phone, I was teaching at the
University of Chicago at the time, and
and Judge Mikva said come back and work
for me at the White House. So it was my
entry into a place that, you know, I never
expected to be. And I spent four years
there, and it was, it was, it was very
important for just really all the rest
of my of my career. And Justice Marshall,
it was just an amazing experience
clerking for Justice Marshall, clerking
for one of the icons of American law and
American history. And you know, he -
I guess it was the year that I
spent with him
that just put into my head, You have to
use what you've been given to - what he
did of course was to promote justice for
more people in more ways than pretty
much anybody else in the legal
profession in his time. And one can
one can never think that one is going to
do that, but but but that's a really
important thing to have in your head as
a goal.
GERKEN: So Justice Sotomayor, may I ask
the same question of you, because you may not
know you have this in common, but both of
you apparently have written
extraordinarily long theses. Seniors out
there get time to get snapping. So Peter
Wynn was your adviser, and he called your
thesis, and I quote, "extremely ambitious
and one of the longest I have ever supervised" but I
wonder if you also might say a few words
about mentors along the way.
SOTOMAYOR: I'll approach the question a little
differently, which is how do you pick a
mentor? Well first of all I'm not sure
you pick them. They mostly pick you. And
the way to do that, I think, is to show
them that you're interested in learning.
And it's sort of surprising to put it
that way, but if you don't seek them out
and actually listen to what they're
saying and put it into some sort of
practice, they're not going to think very
highly of you or really be very
interested in working with you. So you
have to demonstrate your ambition
basically. And the way that most people
do that is by working with them in a way
where you're actually showing them that
you're taking their advice to heart and
following through. That's actually the
most important thing. When a professor
talks to you and makes suggestions it's not
enough to say those are nice. What counts
is coming back and actually implementing
those suggestions in a positive way. So
for me with Peter, and I'll say that the
first mentor I had
was Nancy Weiss, later to become Nancy
Malkiel, and she was the first professor
that I went to at office hours. And my
first question is why did you give me a
C on my paper? And she didn't blow me off.
She actually explained why, and I took to
heart her advice and got a B on my
final paper, but then went and found
Peter, who because he taught Latin
American history understood some of my
language difficulties in writing English
from a Spanish background. And so he was
able to help me learn how to write
properly, but every time he gave me
advice, the one thing I needed was my
next paper had to fix that problem. And I
could, you know, you could make a mistake
once, but you shouldn't make it twice. And
so by the time I finished with him four
years later, I began the process of
writing in a way that led me to my law
degree and to being a judge. But when you
go into the workplace, find people who
are doing things that you admire, that
you don't think you can do, because
finding a mentor who is just going to
show you what you know to me is not very
helpful to me. I always look for those
mentors in my workplace that will help
me understand things and learn how to do
things that I don't think I know how to
do. and so picking the two judges you did,
and I know they had a lot to do in
picking you, obviously, but I'm sure you
had alternatives. They both opened up
different worlds to you and that's what
I've always tried to do with other
mentors throughout my life, to pick
people who can teach me things I'm not
sure that I can do.
KAGAN: Can I just say Professor Weiss did not
give me a very good grade either, so who
knew that we had this in common.
GERKEN: I have a question about
your careers. So Justice Kagan, you were
talking about moving into governement and you know
you made a lot of big jumps in your in
your time, of going into becoming an
academic, going into government, becoming
a dean, the Solicitor General. I know
Justice Sotomayor, you went from IP
litigator, prosecutor to judge.
They're quite different leaps to make -
KAGAN: Short attention span.
GERKEN: I was wondering if you might talk
SOTOMAYOR: It's the beauty of
being a lawyer, by the way.
GERKEN: Right, it's an all purpose degree but I actually do
think that, I mean, whenever I talk to my
1L's, the panic that they have that
they don't know what they want to do in
their first semester, and and you can't
just say to them, you don't even know how
to read a case, in under
four hours, so worry about this later.
But but I think it, I imagine all of
those students here are wondering
whether they really know what they want
to do and whether they're gonna have the
courage to make that jump when they make
it. So how did you know, Justice Kagan,
when to make that jump?
KAGAN: Yeah, so I mean, I did
make a lot of jumps. Before I came to this job,
which has life tenure you know, so I'll
be in this one awhile,
knock wood, but
but basically I changed jobs every four
years or so. And then the in the deanship,
I stayed six years. That was, there was a
lot, so you know, different strokes for
different folks.
Some people they love just finding one
thing, and they want to do it for the
rest of their lives and that's
absolutely fantastic. But for me, the
variety of when you said law allows you
to do that - the variety of things that I
was able to do was really part of the
fun of putting together a legal career.
And what I always think, and it sounds
like you agree with me, Heather, about
advising law students is that they all
have this kind of plan. And first you
have to do step A and then that leads
you to step B and that leads you to step
C and God forbid if you should ever step
off the plan. And I found that all the
most fun things that I did in my career
were mostly the result of serendipity.
I mean it was keeping your eyes open for
opportunities for sure, but just like
lucky things cropping up and and having
the ability to to change direction at a
moment's notice and to say, you know, I
never thought I would do that but that
sounds really like a lot of fun. And and
to be and to be able to step off the
plan, maybe to come back on the plan
maybe not to come back on the plan,
because it leads to another thing that
you would never have done. So I feel as
though my life had a lot of twists and
turns. And you know just for an example, I
was, there I was, I was dean of a law
school, and I thought for sure my next job
was to leave the law entirely. I thought
I was going to go be a university
president someplace as my next job and
then all of a sudden sort of, here I am
doing this.
So you know things work in funny ways
but but but I guess what I would say to
students is just you know be open to
opportunities. Look - things fall into
people's laps that you never expected.
And what you have to do is be
aware that you should grab them.
SOTOMAYOR: I guess I start
with that question by saying
they're very few, if any, fatal mistakes
in life. You know, you can end up in a
dead-end job. You can. But it doesn't mean
you have to stay there.
Lots of people forget that learning is a
lifelong endeavor. I had a mother who
went to college when she was in her late
40s, and she taught me that it's never
too late to retool, never too late to
change directions. So you should explore
your options, think about them a little
bit. But at a certain point you gotta
stop worrying so much. You just gotta
jump in, take a bunch of different
courses, try courses that you know
nothing about. You may fall in love with
one of them. Go to law school and don't
get pegged in one area of law. Go try
different areas. You may end up, believe
it or not it, it could be shocking to some
of you, liking corporate law. There's a
huge number of wonderful lawyers I know
who are terrific people, very interested
in public service, who go in and out of
government all the time, who are
corporate lawyers. There is no occupation
or profession that doesn't and can't
give you an avenue to do good work. You
have to be flexible enough to try new
things, and you have to have the courage
to realize, if you make a wrong choice,
then pick yourself up and move in a
different way. Sometimes people get the
golden handcuffs put on. They're making
so much money they don't want
make a switch. That's a very real
limitation in life. But that shouldn't be
the excuse for unhappiness, and it
shouldn't be the excuse for saying to
yourself, oh my God, am I gonna make a
mistake? You know, what should I do with
my life?
Do with your life. Live it. Take on
adventures. Try new things and then
figure out the thing that seems
interesting and give it a go. If it
doesn't work, shift directions. Do
something else. But don't let the panic
take away from the enjoyment of today. Because look at the opportunities you
have in a place like Princeton. It's
amazing everything this place offers you.
But it won't be valuable unless you're
willing to take chances and do those new
things that might otherwise scare you.
And the same thing in law school.
[APPLAUSE]  GERKEN: This is a question that is
really spurred by a conversation I witnessed
today when a woman who is in one of the
early classes practically embraced a
young grad and said, You don't know what
it was like when there were so few women
on this campus. And what it means now to
look around and see how how much it has
changed. And I know that each of you has
been in many situations as of most of
the women I suspect on the older end - not
that you're in any way -
[LAUGHTER]
KAGAN: Good save
GERKEN: On the more senior end of the
side you both experienced you both experienced
SOTOMAYOR: More experienced.
GERKEN: You both experienced that moment when
you're the only woman in the room and
and Justice Kagan and I wonder if I might
start with you. Um I feel keenly that of
the 194-year history
of my institution only one year has been
helmed by a woman. For me and and I think
you were probably in roughly those same
numbers is the first first woman dean of
Harvard Law School. It was an enormous
moment when that happened and I just
wonder how you thought about occupying
that space and did you feel as a woman
did it feel different? How did it shape
what you did?
KAGAN: You know when I walked in
when you walked into the dean's office
of my predecessor, he had this big thing
on the wall, which was all the different
deans of Harvard Law School. There were I
think about 13 of them. They all served
remarkably long tenures, and I'm sure
that they, I'm sure that they had much
that was different about them.
But when I looked at this picture
it was like 13 of the scariest-looking
older men, older white men, whatever, that -
So the first thing I did was I took
that picture down. But you know you you
you do worry. The faculty was yeah - but by
the time I became dean of the law school,
as for you Heather, the student bodies
are about 50/50 but the faculties are
still, they're still not enough women in
them. And and there and they had never
had a woman dean. And you wonder how are
some of these faculty members going to
deal with that? And are going they you
know going to accept a woman as their
boss? It's hard enough when you're dean.
Actually faculty members do not really
think of you with their boss okay? It's a
little bit hard to establish that
yeah, when you need to. And and then when
you're a woman and when you're a younger
woman, as I was and as you are, and that's
you know it's a hard thing to do. But I
found that in the end, people were very
generous. And I found much more than I
expected, I thought that they were going
to be more problems, more resistance, than
in fact there were. So I was, I was
actually really grateful to all my colleagues.
GERKEN: The art in my office, it's in
the stained glass. They have all the
dean's names carved and then the stained
glasses are criminal punishments, which
include a woman with the giant leather
harness on her face for talking too much
KAGAN: Woo.
GERKEN: and a woman being drowned
as a witch. so I take some pleasure that my
name will be carved on that window. So
Justice Sotomayor, if I might ask you the
same question.
SOTOMAYOR: I don't that you can
be part of the working world without
having a moment, a story, if not more than
one, about being treated differently
because you're a woman. In one of the
classes I had here at Princeton, the
professor had been giving his lecture
for sure close to 40 years, and every time he
got to the point in his lecture where he
was going to tell an off-color joke he
would stop, he would look at me and try
to fix the joke,
couldn't, and then go to something else,
Okay. And the guys would all look at me
and snicker and laugh but I snickered
and laughed with them, but and there are
more. You can't be a professional
woman even today, whether it's in law and
medicine, in any field, without having a
moment where someone is going to treat
you differently because you're a woman.
It comes down to the guy's poker game
Justice Scalia, Justice Scalia was
involved in. It took him a while to invite
me, and I think they were very happy when
I said no. You know I don't know if you
said yes, but the point is that they're there
KAGAN: I was never invited actually.
SOTOMAYOR: But I do it in
reverse. We do it in reverse. We have
poker games and haven't invited any of
them. You can't deny it without
minimizing the fact that it can leave
its moments, it can leave scars and
it can affect the way you feel about
some people and your interactions with
them. But I do think Elena is right that
even at the very beginning of my career,
where there were so few women in
positions of power and I had very few
mentors that I could look to to guide my
development, there were always
men of goodwill and
that's what I call them even today. Men
who understood that equality had to be
put into practice and
men who mentored me
and who supported my career and helped
me along. And there are still those
people out there, and so it is I think
important for all of us for women to
understand that no matter how hostile an
environment may seem, you have to look
around for those people who will come
and stand with you and by you. Because
they are there. And so I guess my point
remains we still have a long way to go,
parroting an old cigarette ad, but it's
a lot shorter distance than when I started out.
GERKEN: So I wonder if I might turn
a little bit to the court and in the
moment in time in which we find
ourselves, so this is a really difficult
moment in terms of politics with, and
there's an enormous amount of
polarization and partisanship around. And
the court has always been understood
as a neutral arbiter, and it's an
incredibly important thing but it's hard
these days when when people have trouble
even talking to one another, let alone
having a shared set of facts and
arguments. And I wonder how you think
about your role on the court at this
moment and how you deal with the
challenge that we all deal with, which is
making sure to be fair to the other side
to see things as they really are, to
check your own views. And Justice Kagan I
wonder if you might just start and talk
a little bit about that.
KAGAN: You know, this is
a really divided time, and part of the
court's strength and and part of the
court's legitimacy depends on people not
seeing the court in the way that people
see the rest of the governing structures
of this country now. In other words
people thinking of the court as not
politically divided in the same way, as
not an extension of politics, but instead
somehow above the fray, even
if not always and in every case. And it's
an incredibly important thing for the
court to guard, is is is this reputation
of of being fair, of being impartial, of
being neutral, and of not being simply an
extension of the terribly polarized
political process and environment that
we live in. And and you know that this is
a challenge. There -
I think people too often don't realize
that we agree on a lot. If you look at
the court's caseload as a whole, you'll
find that about half the time we're
unanimous. On another big chunk of the
time, we have very lopsided votes, but
there are some issues, some important
issues that people care about, in which
the court is more closely divided and
tends to be divided along lines that you
might predict if you looked at who
nominated each of us. I think it's been
an extremely important thing for the
court that, in the last really 30 years,
starting with Justice O'Connor and and
continuing with Justice Kennedy, there
has been a person who people who found
the center, or people couldn't predict in
that sort of way. And that's enabled the
court to look as though it was not owned
by one side or another and and was
indeed impartial and neutral and fair.
And it's not so clear that, you know, I
think going forward that sort of middle
position, you know, it's not so clear
whether we'll have it. And that puts, I
think all of us need to be aware of that,
every single one of us, and to realize
how precious the court's legitimacy is.
You know, we don't need, we don't have an
army and we don't have
any money and the only way we get people
to do what we say that they should do is
because people respect us and respect
our fairness. And I think especially in
this time where the rest of the
political environment is so divided,
every single one of us has an obligation
to think about what it is that provides
the court with its legitimacy and has
you know to think about how we can be
not so politically divided as some of
the other political institutions in the
nation.
[APPLAUSE]
SOTOMAYOR:I'd agree fully with everything
Elena's saying. I think it's important to explain
to people often that part of the
politicization of the court has come
about because our political parties have
adopted the academic discussions that
judges were having for the longest time
about how to interpret laws of the
Constitution. And these were legal
discussions centered around originalism.
Do you interpret the Constitution
according to what you discern the
Founding Fathers would have done or
according to the plain meaning of words?
Versus people who believed and still
believe that originalism has general
principles but that, like our society
today, our Founding Fathers were never
unanimous about what they thought the
answer should be.
And they wrote very broad terms to let
generations that follow give those words
meaning. And so you've got these two sets
of, between originalist and other people,
and you've got plain meaning and people
who say no word is plain, because every
word has to be read in context and
context shades the meaning of everything.
And so those academic discussions have
often led to outcomes that some people
can predic, not always but some. And when
the political parties adopted that
language as their own, they've now
superimposed that on the court.
So originalists get identified as the
choice of a certain group of politicians,
not originalists,
the choice of another group of a
different party. And I think that that
institutionally has hurt the court a lot
and may continue to do so. I do think
that there are structures within the
court, not the least of which is our
modern understanding among, I believe now
we're eight justices, eight justices that
we have to rise above partisanship in
our personal relationships. That we have
to treat each other with respect and
dignity and with a sense of amicability
that the rest of the world doesn't often
share. Elena's relationship with Justice
Scalia is well-known.
KAGAN: Even though he didn't
invite me to his poker game.
SOTOMAYOR: I know.
KAGAN: And apparently did you.
SOTOMAYOR: But you went hunting with him,
and I never would, but and and that same
friendship, by the way with Ruth, and and
there Neil Gorsuch and I are doing a lot
of work together in promoting civic
education in the United States and so
[APPLAUSE]
I think that our openness about
respecting one another is an example
that's important for us to both maintain
and promote. Whether and how we can
accommodate the differences in our
judicial approaches is a much more
difficult question. As on some things as
Justice Ginsberg once said, It's hard.
It's a compromise on fundamental
Constitutional principles and a lot of
those things are what lead to the 5-4
decisions that the public seems to think
are divisive, but we do manage to agree
on lots of things. And to the extent we
can avoid ruling in such expansive ways
as to foreclose continued conversation, I
think we have a chance of holding on to
our legitimacy. As Elena says, though,
we're each going to have to think about
how to do that and how to implement and
support our institutional reputation.
GERKEN: So this follows nicely on one of the
questions from the audience, because I
am struck, you know. I read your 5-4
opinions. You are fierce lawyers. You know
sometimes when you're reading the, hit her
again hit it again. You know it's really,
the lawyer in me is so impressed with
it's hard-hitting, it's frank. You know when
you disagree, you you disagree in a in a
respectful but powerful way. And then I
know how collegial you all are with one
another when you walk off that bench.
I think that's something that most people
don't see and don't know. And and Justice Kagan I wonder if you might talk a little
bit about what are the rituals of
respect that exist inside the court. Is
it the deliberative process? What is it
that you do that enables you to do
something that almost no one else is
able to do at this moment in time, which
is to be friends with the people with
whom you disagree fiercely?
KAGAN: Well I'll say first of all
that I think that there is a little
bit of self-interest going on here,
because we live in this this this this
world where it's just a nine of us. We
are the consummate repeat players. Every
case, it's going to be the same nine of
us. And if you hold grudges, or if you you
know have a bad relationship with one of
your colleagues, then in the next case
and in the next case and in the next
case, you have a not much of a chance of
persuading that colleague to come along
with what you think is the right thing
to do. So so we all have a kind of vested
interest in having good relations with
each other, and I think that that's part
of what maintains our good behavior. But
I will say that I think that it's it's
it's something more than that. And I
don't think it's necessary - if you look
at the history of the Supreme Court,
there are some parts of the court's
history where people had completely
pathological relationships, where they
wouldn't talk with each other, where one
person walked into a room and another
person would walk out. And we don't have
any of that. We actually -
SOTOMAYOR: Read "Scorpions"
by Noah Feldman. It's a wonderful read
even for non-lawyers, and it we'll talk
about that, one of those periods in our history.
KAGAN: Absolutely. And we are very much
not like that. I think we all get along
genuinely very well. I think we we we all
believe that everybody is operating in
good faith around the table, even if we
disagree strongly with them. You know so
what what what what accounts for that
I'm not sure. I think partly it's
personalities. I think that the the chief
justice is very good about setting the
tone that for the entire institution. We
have lunch all the time. Now this might
seem it's a little thing, but every time
we have arguments, and every time we meet
in conference to talk about cases, we
always follow that by with a lunch
together in the justices dining room.
And there are rules about, you can't talk
about work, you can't talk about cases,
you can so we got to know a lot about
you know each other's families.
Or we talk about books or movies or
sports, or you know various things, and
you know it just
SOTOMAYOR: We tell bad jokes
KAGAN: We tell bad jokes. I won't say
which of our colleagues are sort of the
Masters of the bad jokes okay. It's
neither of the two of us, but you know we
laugh, we groan, and I think that those
kinds of I don't know whether to
call lunch an institutional
arrangement, but sort of do help to keep
things a little bit lighter than they
might otherwise be. So you know we do get
annoyed with each other sometimes, and as
the year goes by the annoyances tend to
add up a little bit. So I've always
thought that, much as in the academic
environment, one of the great things
about really getting along with each
other is that we get to escape each
other in the summers. And you you know,
you you escape each other. You you're
away from people and you actually, when
you when you come back, you realize how
much you miss them and how much you like
them and how much you appreciate them.
SOTOMAYOR: How I do it in life generally is I try
to find the good in every person. If you
start from the proposition that there is
something good in everybody, it's a lot
easier to get along with them,
even when you disagree vehemently.
And so for me, I tell people often who don't
know, Justice Clarence Thomas knows every
employee in our building, and not only
knows their names, but he knows all their
family members. If someone gets ill, he's
the first one to reach out and offer help.
He is exceedingly caring
whenever anyone, myself I can
speak for myself, but I know he does it
with everybody. If you're ill, if you've
had someone die in your family, his are
the first flowers that arrive. It's the
first call that's made
to see if you're okay.
He and I I don't think voted together on
hardly anything, but I know that inside
of him there is a goodness
that I can admire.
Might disagree with him on everything
else, but I think if you can approach
people in that way and understand that a
difference of opinion doesn't
necessarily brand you an evil person,
there's more space to talk, there's more
space to engage, and certainly more space
for willingness to compromise. And you
know the master of that was probably
Tony Kennedy. Tony Kennedy I think spent
all of his time trying to find the best
in his colleagues and I think that's why
he could find middle ground so often.
GERKEN: One of the things that is
so striking about your opinions and
particularly your dissents is that they
speak to people who don't have law
degrees. So law can be very technical.
When judges write, they often write quite
abstractly, but you two are both able to
crystallize issues in a way that's
accessible to people who are reading the
newspaper. I actually think in some ways
you share that with Justice Scalia, that
you're able to read it and understand
the stakes and it's very powerful.
I wonder, especially when you're writing
dissents, how do you think about uses of
emotion, how do you think
about that crisp phrase that's you know
is gonna be in the front page of the New
York Times?
How do you think about when to do it,
when to play that card and when not to
play that card? And I ask you in
particular because there is some
possibility that you may be dissenting
more often in the future, and so I wonder
you know if you imagine yourselves as
lawyers, as justices, but also as
dissenters, how do you how do you think
about how you write the opinion and and
when to play this sort of one of those
cards? And Justice Sotomayor, I wonder if
I might talk to you because I know you
know sometimes you speak quite
personally, even emotionally, in some of
your dissents. And I wonder if you might
talk about when you think about doing
that and why.
SOTOMAYOR: I lost two cases in a row
early in my career as a prosecutor and I
went to my supervisor, and he sat down
and he said how did you present your
case, cases? And I went through it and he
said, My
that's so logical. That's why you lost.
You didn't convince the jury that it was
their obligation to convict. And I looked
at him and I said what? And he said, you
know jurors are human beings who don't
want to pass judgment on another person,
and it's very hard for them to say that
person is guilty or to imagine that
maybe that person is going to go to jail.
And when you're presenting your case, you
have to not only convince them that this
is what the evidence proves, but that
it's also their obligation to convict. He
said that to me and I did not lose
another case and I think I tried 30
cases after that. I had a couple of hung
juries and I'd had a couple of less than
the top charges, but I never lost another.
Now it doesn't mean I when I write that
way you have to marshal the evidence. You
have to prove the case. But you have to
convince a reader of the moral justice
in your position. And I think that it's
not every case requires that. You know
we've got more than 50% of cases that
that we agree upon, and I if I wrote that
way for all 50 of those, I'd never get a
unanimous court again. But we do because
we write in certain ways when you have,
you're trying to draw more votes. But
when there is something that you
understand to be fundamental and if you
want to have people understand your
position and what you're arguing, then I
do think that explaining it in a way
that people can feel is critical. I
probably don't do it more than once or
twice a year, because it has to be that
fundamental case that people need to
understand and need to understand that
the choice is right under the law. And so
for me it's not hard to come to those
moments. I do think that writing so
people understand your cases or your
position is always important. Writing the
most complex case in simple ways is
terribly important but I will tell you
even though we work hard at that, I bet
the majority of people never read a
Supreme Court case.
They read the the quips in the New York
Times. They read summaries in some other
form. If I were to ask this room how
many of you have read a Supreme Court
case cover to cover, I bet that
two-thirds of you never have. And so you
do it in the hopes that the person who
does pick it up will understand and in
the hope that if what you're explaining
can touch people, that they will read more
than they normally do.
GERKEN: Justice Kagan, I wonder if I
might ask you the same question. There was
a First Amendment case this year where
you wrote extremely powerful dissent and
crystallized a set of cases and as they
were moving through, and when when we all
read that phrase "the weaponization of
the First Amendment" it was it was
something that everyone in the academy
stood up and listened, and all the lawyers
stood up and listened. It was really
powerful, because we knew you don't do
that often. And I just wonder, how did you
think about, without being too specific
about any case, how do you think about this?
KAGAN: Right, you don't do it often and you
can't do it often for just the reasons
that Justice Sotomayor said, is you know,
there are different kinds of dissents.
There are dissents where you think
that the majority has gotten it wrong,
and you think, you know, I should say that
there's another way to understand this
question, but in the next case, in the
next case, in the next case, you're going
going to go along with the majority's
position. You've had your say, now it's
time to to join the precedent that's
been created and nothing about your
dissent in a case like that ought to be
you know, so so powerful. Right? You
should try to tell people why you're
right, but it's not, the
world doesn't depend on it. But every
once in a while, you you see a case which
seems - sometimes these cases they stand
in for bigger issues. It's not just the
case itself. It's what you fear the case
signifies for the future. It's what, it's
it's the case, and the next case, and the
next case, and you can see how the court
is going down a road that you think is
profoundly dangerous, and and then you
have to say so, and you have to say what
you find dangerous about it and why you
think that there that there is this danger.
And and you know, in an attempt, if not
now, then next year or next year, or the
year after that, or 10 years or 20 years,
you know to get people to reevaluate
where that, what the court has done and
where the court is going. And those
dissents have to be written in a
different way if you're really speaking
to the next generation and if you're
saying here's what the court has done
wrong and here's how we you know need
to reverse this, I mean you got up your
rhetoric a little bit. Now I tend not to,
I think like some of the opinions that
Sonia has written that are emotional are
really powerful, but I tend not to try to
get people to feel things, but I it's
just sort of not the way I write, but but
but I want them to think they have
gotten it so wrong.
And so I guess I guess maybe to feel
that, to feel to feel that their logic,
that their legal analysis, their use of
precedent, that and their, you know, that
their selection of fundamental legal
principles is is just really wrong.
SOTOMAYOR: We are very different.
KAGAN: So that's what you
try to do, what I try to do.
GERKEN: I wonder if I might ask you a little bit about
being a first. There was only four women who have
worn this robe. I remember when Justice
Ginsburg joined the court, and she was up
there with Justice O'Connor, and one of
the advocates mixed them up, even though
I'll just say, they really don't look
anything alike, different politics
different different accents, everything
you could ask for. And so yeah there's a
lot of studies about what happens with
women on the bench, do they get
interrupted more, how do counsel treat
them, do they mix them up for one another,
and I wonder when you have, when you
put that robe on, do you feel it? Do you
feel that gap or are you un-self-conscious about your gender?
I'm just curious about how you how you inhabit
that role, maybe Justice Kagan?
KAGAN: I really don't feel it on the bench.
There have actually been these these these
studies recently that have surprised me,
because they're so not in keeping with
my experience of it there. And the
studies they insist that the women on
the bench, and particularly the two of us,
get interrupted more than our male
colleagues still, in a way that you know
in lots of other parts of my life, that
has struck me as a common experience,
that women get interrupted more than men
do, that women have an idea and nobody
really responds to it and then a man
repeats the idea and everybody says, Wow,
that is amazing.
But I have to say that on the bench I
think that those statistics about
interruption have much more to do with
the fact that there's, that Sonia and I
are relatively junior justices and that
there is a practice of, if two people
start talking at the same time, which is
often the case at the court because
there are a lot of talkers on the court,
and and and so the moment you see a
sort of pause, you jump, two people jump
in, and one of them has to step back. And
I think we tend to step back a little
bit because we're junior justices, but my
sense of the bench now is, you know, there
are three women on the bench and Justice
Sotomayor and I sit on opposite sides of
the bench, and Justice Ginsburg sits in
the middle. None of us are shrinking
violets. We all, you know, ask lots of
questions. We all can give lawyers a good
run for their money, and I think if you
come to the Supreme Court, it's like wow
there are these women's voices from all
over the place, from this side and that
side, in the center, and and they're just
kind of coming at you. And it seems to me
we don't take a backseat role.
SOTOMAYOR: I was just gonna say that I don't disbelieve
the statistics.
I accept them as true. I
think the difference is that not one of
us three are shrinking violets, and we
just don't care.
[APPLAUSE]
Because of it and because I think we
just accept it and just move on from
there, and it doesn't stop us from doing
whatever we think we need to do, or
getting a clarification to a question we
think is important, that it really
doesn't affect us. You know it was Ruth
who at a public event not so long ago
said and this may be true for her for a
slightly different reason, Justice
Ginsberg speaks very softly and it's
sometimes very hard to hear her, but she
said that there were moments where she
would say something and go around the
table and some male in our group would
say something and it was a great idea
coming from him and not her. Whether
that's because of the softness of her
tone or gender dynamics in place it's
hard to tell, but I do think it does
happen, and but I do think that given the
nature of the court and the fact that we
all understand that we're one among nine
and that our votes are equal in that
respect, that it doesn't affect us as
much.
GERKEN: So it's a great job you have so I
know you won't be complaining, but but it
does require you to give things up. You
know the different roles require
different things of you. I mean Justice
Kagan, I remember speaking to you just
after you become Solicitor General and
you'd left running this giant law school.
You have this extraordinary law school,
this massive operation, and students,
faculty, alumni, all these things and and
I remember you said the phone doesn't
ring that much when you were SG, and I
imagine you both now are in a completely
different role than you've been before.
So I wonder as you think what is it that
you'd given up, what is it what are the
things you can't do, the things that you
can't say, that you would have done in an
instant at some other point because
you're both reasonably blunt. So I'm curious.
KAGAN: The phone doesn't ring. I track my jobs
in terms of emails received. I used to,
when I was dean, used to get 400
500 emails a day, and then when
I was Solicitor General, I got about 40.
And now, when I get an email, it is such
an exciting moment in my life. I don't know.
You know you know different different
different jobs have different
constraints that go along with them. And
and I've been in other jobs too where I
haven't been able to to do whatever I
wanted to do or to say whatever I
wanted to say. You're a dean. I mean my
view of the deanship was that as to
various issues that my students and my
faculty and my alumni were very divided
on that my job was to trying to be
neutral and and to play it straight. And
and so I think I'm I'm used to feeling
that there are some, every job has, what
goes along with the job is some set of
constraints. This is what you can't do
and still be able to do your job
effectively and well and according to
the ethical rules of the job or or that
will allow you to serve the goals of the
job. And so this job doesn't feel all
that different to me from others in that
respect. That sure there's a lot of stuff that I can't
talk in public about. There's some stuff that I feel
as though I shouldn't even really think
about, but I think that's that's true
most things in the world.
SOTOMAYOR: I don't disagree with
the basic point but I do
think that, more than the other jobs I
had, and I was a judge for 17 years
before this, first of all I won't wear
shorts anymore.
You do have to be careful about what you
wear, which when I was a judge before it
people would never think of taking a
picture of me when I walked around my
neighborhood. Now that I'm a justice they
would and they do. I'm careful at beaches.
You know, I, but that also goes to my
conversation in public. When I was a
regular judge, whatever that means but
when I was a judge on the court of
appeals and on the district court, I
could go and express an opinion to a
friend privately and never had to fear
that it would go public. That's not quite
the same today and not because I don't
think my friends intend to spread
private comments, but they inadvertently
might say something to a friend who then
will report it publicly. And that sort
of thing makes you much more guarded
than I ever thought I had to be before.
And even when you tell jokes, people take
them seriously. You you get stuff back
and calls from the press, did you say
this and you go what? There
is, you give up quite a bit of public
life and being open and blunt but it
also I think to some degree makes you
more guarded even in your private life.
GERKEN: So now I'm goint to ask about your private life, since a lot of the questions wanted to just know
just this one simple question, what on
earth do you do for fun and and if I
just may ask my own version of it, which
of you is a better poker player?
KAGAN: She is!
SOTOMAYOR: That's really,
we both like poker. We
have fun with that. I love food and I
love going to great restaurants. I have
champagne and beer tastes, so I can go
very high-end and I can go to dives, and
I love both of them.
I do bicycle ride when I'm not injured.
This year you know has been a bad year
for me, and I like spending time with my
friends. I like cooking. I like you know
just laughing about things that's not my
work. So I do have fun. Actually this is
fun. I don't I don't -
Elena and I work together, we're in
conference together, we're in the court
together, but it's rare that we have a
plane ride here together or just a few
hours just to pass the time.
KAGAN: Sometimes we go out for a meal.
The two of us definitely know more restaurants in
Washington D.C. than any of our colleagues -
SOTOMAYOR: Put together, yeah, we
do, we do.
So I know you read a lot.
KAGAN: I read a lot. I
go to movies.
SOTOMAYOR: That I don't do as much.
KAGAN: Try to do some exercise every once in
a while, see friends, normal things. And
actually you know what, it affects your
life a lot less than you might think, at
least for me. I think Sonia's a little
bit more recognized than I am, or maybe a
lot more recognized, because her face is
on the cover of all of these books, but I
find for me that as long as I put on a
hat and sunglasses, so so in the winter
it's a little bit weird, you know, to put
on the sunglasses, but I could do most
things without without making a scene.
You know, sometimes I'll be aware, I'll be
in a restaurant and I'll be, you know,
people will be like over there, you know,
but Washington D.C. has its share of
public officials. and I think people
don't get all that terribly excited
about seeing another one. And,
you know, for the most part, we live very
normal lives.
GERKEN: Alright, this is just a quick one.
If this we're not your, the job of your
destiny, what would be the job of your
destiny, if you could just pick any job
other than this one that you have, what
would you do?
KAGAN: That you really want to do?
GERKEN: That you really want to do.
KAGAN: Even if you have none
of the talents?
GERKEN: None of the talents. You can
trapeze artist if you want to pick it. What would you do?
SOTOMAYOR: Oh you're gonna have to answer that. No I'll tell you why I'm in my
perfect position, but I don't mean as a
Supreme Court justice. I loved being a
lawyer, I loved being a district court
judge, circuit court judge. I love being a
Supreme Court justice. The law was my
dream and I have always been happy in my
life in my life. There really wasn't
anything that I could aspire to be like
that except maybe a salsa dancer.
You know, because I couldn't do it and
because even now I do it, but I don't do
it with the natural grace that I would
love if I could have found that talent. I
would have been Rita Moreno on stage, you
know, something like that, yeah.
KAGAN: I think I'd be Serena Williams or something.
[LAUGHTER]
but but then I doubt that she'd still be
doing it at my age, so I'm glad I have
this job instead.
[LAUGHTER]
SOTOMAYOR: Think of Billie Jean King. How old was she when she played Bobby Riggs?
KAGAN: Definitely younger than I am now.
[LAUGHTER]
GERKEN: I'm going to say the one thing that's gonna
displease everyone in this room, which is this is
our last question, and so I wonder if I
just might ask you a question about the
effect that Princeton had on you. I mean
this is a place where we all came to
grow up. We all began our professional
lives. We have a set of memories. I'm
struck Justice Sotomayor, when I came
back as trustees, how embedded it was
even just in the physical layout of the
place, that memories just flooded back to
me, and so I wonder as you look back, what
has stuck with you from Princeton.
SOTOMAYOR: It easier for me to answer this, because
it was so transformational for me, and it
affected my entire existing life then
and everything that has come since.
It opened the door to opportunity for me in
a way that I never imagined, even when I
accepted attending Princeton. I tell a
story in my book of my mother and I
shopping for a raincoat that I could
bring with me to Princeton. And we were
shopping in the South Bronx's most famous
shopping area, at Alexander's for those
of those - it was a little less than
Macy's, lot less, but we were treated with
such awe by the salespeople
when I told them I was attending
Princeton. And as we walked out my mother
looked at me and said, what have you
gotten us into now?
And I didn't know. I didn't really
understand what it meant to come to a
place like Princeton and all of the
changes that it would create in me. How
much I would grow up, not just in my
writing skills and my thinking skills,
but in my life skills, getting along with
people who were so vastly different from
me. And so that gift is one I treasure. It is
my enduring, my enduring gift from
Princeton. And so it took lots of years
to be convinced to become a trustee,
because I was so busy in my life, and
when I finally did I was so glad I had.
And it's my hope that more women in this
room will aspire to that, because it's
still important to have women trustees
who want to participate actively in in
growing this institution more but that
is my most enduring gift, who I became.
KAGAN: Well, I feel as though I got the best
education in Princeton, and I made the
best friends, so part of what I got out
of Princeton is a set of friends whom I
keep in touch with and who are really
important to me however many years later.
How many years later is it? It's coming up there.
SOTOMAYOR: More for me.
KAGAN: And I got this great education where
people really forced me to to think
about issues and problems in not
simple-minded ways, and to keep pushing
the envelope, and to keep challenging
myself, and to keep thinking about
different points of view, and to keep
wondering whether I had gotten it right,
or whether there was more to think about.
And that's something that is is has been
enormously helpful throughout my career.
GERKEN: I know I know that everyone in this room
feels like the debt goes the other way,
so I would just ask the audience to join
me in thanking the justices for being here.
[APPLAUSE]
please join me in thinking the justices
again and I have a request if you please
will stay seated as they leave the adwin
gym that would be terrific thank you
what
I'm sorry
after the justices have left the room
that conference participants can begin
to go to dinner and the members of the
community who are not registered at the
conference can please go downstairs and
exit thank you so much for being here